welcome to the first University lecture
of our 2009 and 10 academic year I want
to especially thank the trustees the
administrators the faculty members and
the students who are here with us this
evening
I want to extend a special welcome to
dr. Dorothy Steele the wife of our
featured speaker today
Dorothy is one of the nation's experts
on early childhood education before
coming to New York she served as the
executive director of the Center for
comparative studies in race and
ethnicity at Stanford University and on
behalf of Jean my wife and me we want to
extend our personal welcome to you
Dorothy and
this lecture series is part of a
Colombia tradition dating back to 1971
when the Columbia professor and literary
critic Lionel trilling delivered the
first University lecture I have come to
realize that Columbia that if you want
to start a tradition asked Lionel
trilling to be the first participant
since then at least twice a year the
university affords a distinguished
member of the faculty the opportunity to
share with us the insights the person
has gained from the particular course of
study today we are especially delighted
to welcome to the stage our new
University provost and professor of
psychology Claude Steele as most of you
know Claude has succeeded Alan Brinkley
as Columbia's 21st Provost and for the
past few weeks he has been working hard
to get to know us and the larger
Columbia community he has met with a
number of Dean's administrators faculty
and students and he and Dorothy and
their golden retriever Theo are settling
in to a life in New York after many
years as part of the Stanford University
community Claude and Dorothy had some
major decisions to make as they
considered whether or not to move to New
York
one of the weightiest involved a
potential sibling rivalry rivalry
between their daughter jory who lives in
San Francisco and their son Benjamin who
lives here in New York they were faced
with a tug-of-war between leaving jory
their son-in-law and their four-month
old grandchild Matthew in California and
having the chance to move closer to
Benjamin their daughter-in-law and their
10 month old grandchild
Coleman who live in Brooklyn lucky for
us
Benjamin one and we must however expect
Claude and Dorothy to make regular trips
back to California to spend time with
their daughter Jory and little Matthew
and if we know anything about psychology
we know they've already concluded but
all things considered the decision to
move here was for the best at Stanford
Claude served most recently as the Lucy
Stern professor and Social Sciences
director of the Center for comparative
studies in race and ethnicity and
director of the Center for Advanced
Study in the behavioral sciences in
addition to his impeccable record as a
teacher and administrator Claude is a
recognized leader in the field of social
psychology his research focuses on the
psychological experience of the
individual and particularly on the
experience of threats to the self and
the consequences of those threats
his early work considered the self-image
threat self affirmation and its role in
self-regulation
and the role of alcohol and drug abuse
in self-regulation processes and social
behavior well my colleague actually
Claude was at the University of Michigan
in the late 1980s he began to turn his
attention to the puzzle of why very
capable minority students were doing
less well academically then their levels
of accomplishment at entry would predict
this led him to develop the theory of
stereotype threat the phenomenon whereby
the threat of confirming a stereotype
about one's group disrupts one's
performance in an activity the theory
has proved very useful in understanding
group differences in performance ranging
from the intellectual to the athletic
prova steel is widely recognized and is
the recipient of numerous fellowships
and awards including the deans award
from Stanford Teaching Award and the
American Psychological associations
award for distinguished contributions to
psychology in the public interest he has
also taught at the University of Utah
and as I mentioned the University of
Michigan and the University of
Washington Claude is a friend and a
colleague to many of us in the Columbia
community his work has had a profound
impact not only on academic scholarship
but also it has influenced academic and
public policy this is something I know
firsthand as his research was
instrumental and we drew on it a lot in
the Gruder decision of 2003 when the
Supreme Court upheld affirmative action
in admissions policies and universities
across the country our own professor of
psychology Geraldine downing credits
Claude's research for guiding many of
the strategies the university has
employed in increasing diversity among
our faculty in recent years Claude's
lecture this evening is based on his
upcoming book whistling Vivaldi and
other clues to how stereotypes affect us
through the use of dramatic life stories
Claude shares the experiments and
studies that repeatedly show the
negative impact stereotypes can have on
academic performance and he shows how
both the targets and the perpetrators of
such such stereotypes how to break this
cycle it is very clear that while our
new Provost has much to learn from us we
too have much to learn from him
in thinking about how to introduce and
welcome Claude to the Columbia community
it seemed after all was said and done
the best way was a radical one of simply
sitting and listening to him talk about
his ideas
ladies and gentlemen is my great
pleasure to present Columbia University
Provost and today's lecturer Claude
Steele
Thank You Lee for those words they're
kind and generous and much appreciated I
couldn't have a better introduction to
the Columbia community than then that
set of remarks and so I much appreciate
it I'll also just take this opportunity
to say how happy we are to be here at
Columbia one thing we're happy to have
over is the move
you know moves are pretty traumatic the
the upheaval involved and so we're
really happy to be settling in at this
point but we also find Columbia just to
be an exciting and interesting
University and a place with a great deal
of potential and I know every day is a
kind of maybe I'm having the thrill of
an anthropologist you know learning
about a new place but but it's been an
awful lot of fun and so I want to
express some some appreciation there my
mission tonight is really to describe my
research activities over the last 20
years in about 35 minutes by my by my
count so I'll do the best I can and in
that respect but you should never trust
an academic you know they're always a
little pushing the time so give me a
signal if it goes on too too long this
is this is work which I think can be
roughly summarized with with the the
term stereotype threat and a social
identity threat which is a broader
version of that I I'm a social
psychologist an experimental social
psychologist and and one of the the
thrills of being a social psychologist
is that it
it's that science which is pitched at
every day tries to understand everyday
social life and experience it's not
focused on the galaxy it's not focused
on molecular structures it's focused on
the level of analysis is everyday
experience you get to sort of peer back
from the surface of things and you look
in and you see what you find it
oftentimes you find things that are very
counterintuitive about what goes on
everyday life and I hope you'll get a
little bit of that sensation as I
describe the course of this research
that's one way of thinking about how it
felt to us the the part of everyday life
that got us started we're really two
problems to real world problems as Lee
alluded to the first is the
underperformance in school and on tests
of groups in society whose whose
intellectual abilities are negatively
stereotyped a lot of this work as you'll
see has focused on the experience of
women in quantitative math and
quantitatively based fields the sciences
engineering and and the like and an
awful lot of it is also focused on the
experience of minority students pretty
much across the academic board this is a
as I say a twenty-year-old research a
topic at this point so there are now
studies looking at everything from
academic performance to athletic
performance I'm gonna stick today on the
on the academic theme so that's one
problem
that God has started the other problem
might be called the diversity problem
for lack of a better term and the idea
here is that you know it's one thing to
numerically integrate a setting a
classroom a school a workplace it's one
thing to numerically integrate that
setting it's a very different thing to
make that setting a place where
everybody regardless of their identity
feels like they can flourish in the
situation and that they can
unselfconsciously engage the the task
the Manifest task of the situation how
do you make a situation work like that
work for everybody that's the the second
sort of practical problem that launches
that has launched this this work I'm
going to talk a lot in this talk about
the academic focus of this research but
I hope that you'll get at least as a
back theme some idea about how these
processes working in your own lives I do
think that everybody experiences
stereotype threat at least a couple of
times a day and I hope by the end of the
talk you have a sense of when you're
experiencing and when you're not and
what it's about and what the reactions
to it might be so I have both a focus
and a larger
ambition for what what you get out of
this the organization will be a little
bit of theory a little bit of evidence
and then a little bit of remedy what to
do about this this problem so it will
sound maybe a little analytical and a
little of boy he's for separating on the
difficulties but at the end I'm working
towards some framework for remedy and
solution and I think over the last six
years that's where the most exciting
research in this area has been focused
okay I'll begin with a very simple
concept I wish I could see that better
than I could read it but but the the
idea of social identity I puts as a
standard textbook definition of of
social identity it's the part of
personal identity one sense of one's on
oneself that comes from group
memberships in the social categories to
which we belong and I really put that up
so that you'll see the long list of
social identities that we we have age
sex race religion profess an ethnicity
nationality sexual orientation political
affiliation mental health status these
are all social identities that that they
all meet that definition and one way of
thinking about the the thrust of this
research is what is it that makes a
given social identity very important to
us and important in how we function and
we have a very simple answer to that
question maybe maybe it's too simple but
we're pushing it right now the answer is
if the things you have to deal with in
particular situations because you have
the identity if you have to deal with
things in situations because you have
the identity then that identity is
likely to become very important to you
that's the argument if you do not have
to deal with things that are of great
importance to you based on having an
identity then that identity is is it's
not really central to your functioning
it may be something that you know about
it may be something you have a
historical interest in there are ways of
relating to it but it won't be central
to how you function on a daily basis
that's the strong argument the thing
that the term that we use to do refer to
this
this the things you have to deal with
because you have an identity our
identity contingencies contingencies of
identity that's what that that's what
that term is designed to to refer to
I'll give you an example I have been
writing this book and it does have a bit
of a memoir structure to it and at one
point I remember asking myself what is
the what moment did I did I realize I
was black when did that strike me and to
the best of my memory which no good
psychologist trusts entirely but to the
best of my memory I think it happened
when I was in the second or third grade
and it was like the last day of school
and we were on our way home from school
and somebody started talking about the
fact that we couldn't go to the swimming
pool that was about three blocks away
except on Wednesday afternoons and I I
just I just couldn't believe that and
yeah the idea was that we couldn't go to
the swimming pool
except on windy Wednesday afternoons
because we were black and it was just
kind of discourse about this and people
are trying to figure it out and we're
we're all upset about it and what could
this mean and you know an
eight-year-olds mind is struggling with
this with this question and and you know
questions that you're never going to get
an answer to what why is this the
important to everybody that we can't go
swimming everybody else can go swimming
all the time and we can't goes with it's
a question and the most important
feature of the question I think for the
purpose for the purposes I'm using it
here is to is that it's the question
that makes you aware you've got an
identity that you are black that it has
some particular meaning in this
situation you don't know what it is you
don't know why it is you don't know when
it's gonna be relevant to you when it's
not gonna be relevant to you but this is
like a scary fact because it means that
at some point it could be relevant to
you you can't put it down you'd like to
put it down but you can't put it down so
it becomes something that moves inside
and you start to think about it and you
elaborate it and you relate to other
people on the basis of who has the
identity and who doesn't has the
identity and it starts to become
something that structures your
experience of the world and I'm arguing
that without that kind of thing
an identity just doesn't do all that it
doesn't move in and doesn't do all that
that worked for us if if you know if you
were in a society where everybody was
black for example let's say I was in
Lagos Nigeria that particular identity
might not be very psychologically
significant for me not in the same way
it is in this context it's it's a
contextual thing so you can see the
implications here I'd love to go on
talking about this but I got so much to
cover I'm gonna have to race over things
but I suppose the main point I'm trying
to make with this illustration is that
identity is very situational the
identities that mean a lot to us in this
particular situation may not mean that
much to us in another situation I go to
Europe I experience race in a very
different way than experience it here
and it has to do with how the society is
organized around that identity the
things that you have to deal with
because you have the identity the other
point I want to make is that I'll have
to get my pointer here some
contingencies are more important than
other contingencies there we go that's
that I want to make this claim here by
affecting the comfort level and the
performance pressure that we feel in
specific situations and an entire walks
of life identity contingencies can
affect both specific performances life
defining choices of careers
relationships regions of the country to
live in and so on I want to argue that
these identities to grow out of
contingencies that grow out of the way a
society is organized around identities
have huge implications for for us we
tend to think in this society especially
that that as individuals individual
these things aren't that much aren't
that important to us or that they're not
important to us unless we let them be
that important to us and I'm trying to
stress here the kind of reality that
makes identities important to us the
other thing I want to argue is stress in
the in this part of the talk is that a
contingencies that threaten us are put
surely gripping they really do get our
attention and they really do galvanize
these identities and this is a quote
that puts that pretty well it's from a
great book I recommend in the name of
identity by a min Maloof on how
explaining violence that in defensive
and identity people can be more violent
than they than they often are a
defensive themselves at any rate people
often see themselves in terms of
whichever one of their allegiances or
identities is under attack whether he
accepts or conceals it proclaims that
discreetly or flaunts it it is with that
allegiance that identity that the person
identifies so when one feels under some
threat just imagine a situation you're
the only man in the room you're the only
woman in the room you're the only old
guy in the room I've recently had more
of those experiences than I'd like you
you feel that identity what will it mean
how will I be seen well how will people
respond to my work on and on that those
that's the sense that you could be under
threat based on an identity pushes this
identity and it makes it especially
powerful for us okay I think that's
really all the theory I want to bring up
at this point this is just a summary
that says social identities originated
from and are sustained by contingencies
that go with them in particular
situations that's that's a claim and the
second claim is that the most
psychologically impactful contingencies
are those that threaten us those are the
two operating assumptions that I'm
making now I want to move into the
research the experiments that that
capture the test experiment of
stereotype threat because stereotype
threat is a perfect example of an
identity contingency it's a very subtle
identity contingency and so one that
might not be might be tempted to think
it's not very powerful but you'll see I
think that it can be quite powerful what
it is is simply being in a situation or
doing something for which a negative
stereotype about one of your identities
applies to you or could be applied to
you that's all it takes just be
in a situation for which a negative
stereotype about one of your identities
could be applied to you in that
situation at that moment at some level
often implicit you have the realization
that you could be judged or treated in
terms of that stereotype and if you care
about what you're doing this is an
important point if you care about what
you're doing in that situation the
prospect of being snagit of lis
stereotype like that are reduced to a
stereotype can be upsetting and
distracting and can interfere with your
functioning in that situation that's
just that's the basic idea
as you can see stereotype threat is not
something that is a piece of a person's
personality it's a it's a person is a
part of the situation we realize it
because we know the culture we're in and
we know the stereotypes that are in it
and we know we're doing something that's
relevant to it and then we we know that
we could be judged that way or treated
that way that's where the threat arises
so aren't our idea was if could this be
a factor in this problem I mentioned at
the outset of the talk on the
underperformance on cognitive tests and
in academic situations our very first
experiment looked at this as an account
of why women might underperform on a
difficult math test so we did this as
years ago at the University of Michigan
a simple experiment we got men and women
who were really good at math and cared
an awful lot about math they were
invested in it as a as a career path for
themselves there's their sophomores in
college at this at this point they had
high scores high grades and and the like
we brought them into the laboratory one
at a time and gave them a really
difficult math test a half an hour
section of the Graduate Record exam you
take if you're a math major so really
not the quantitative section but the
math section of the the of the GRE our
idea was that for the women for women
this would be a very different
experience than it would be for the men
and this is where you can start to we
argue the women in this situation have
different contingencies of identity that
make the experience of taking a test
like that
a very different experience
for them for them when they start to
experience frustration on that test the
stereotype of in this society let's call
it the Larry Summers stereotype for for
lack of just a put a fine point on it
that stereotype rears its head and
becomes a plausible explanation of the
experience of the emotion of the
frustration that the person is having in
that situation and remember these are
women who care about doing well at math
so the prospect of of even in this
situation privately there alone in a
room taking a test but the prospect for
these women to confirm that kind of
stereotype could be upsetting and it
might begin to interfere with their
performance that was our idea for men
the they're too heavily invested in
doing well in math this is a equally
frustrating test for them they they
could find out that they themselves as
individuals aren't very good at math but
they're not at risk of confirming
anything as like a group-based
limitation of ability that's not on the
line for them and one thing I'd say is
an aside I think it's we learned in this
research is often much more upsetting to
think that something that you're being
limited in life because of your of a
group identity that it is to think that
you're being limited in life because of
your own limitations that's that's a
little bit more acceptable than thinking
that it's something about your group so
our prediction was women in this
situation would not do as well as the
men even though they are equally
selected them carefully for being
equally qualified and let's see this is
what happens it's a very dramatic
difference there the bar on your left
the dark bar is is women's performance
on this half hour section of the test
and the tall white bars men's
performance on this section of the of
the test so what we had expected
happened however there is a Larry
Summers interpretation to this
particular pattern of data which is that
well there really are biological
differences between men and women in
math performance that manifests
themselves when a test is very
difficult and that's what you're picking
up here you're not picking up any a
repression of women's math performance
by stereotype threat you're just picking
up what some of us may have suspected
all along so to separate the two
explanations you needed a condition
where you could basically do this
experiment over again but this time
given instruction that would lift
stereotypes threat out of the situation
that would make women not experience
stereotype threat in this situation and
the way we did that after a lot of I
mean it really took about it a year or
so to come up with a decent way of doing
this it turned out to be very simple we
just said to them before they took the
test you may have heard that women don't
do as well as men on difficult
standardized math tests but that's not
true for this particular test on this
particular test women always do as well
as men is you know just just you
couldn't do nothing about the implicit
messages nothing about your performance
here could confirm anything about your
being a woman so when you do that and
you do the experiment over again you get
that the woman's performance comes up
dramatically I've got this thing pointed
correctly and you know as I often say if
it wasn't for that effect I probably
wouldn't be standing here it was it was
these data I can't carry these around in
my pair in my these are ancient data of
many much more contemporary
demonstrations of this but it's almost
like a superstition I carry these around
because they were the ones that first
made it clear that will something like
this could be a factor and something
that we typically see is almost
unmodifiable you think of cognitive
abilities as something you sit somebody
down in front of a test and you're
pretty much going to get at the heart of
their of their cognitive abilities and
this is arguing that well there are
contingencies of identity that can make
in certain circumstances very dramatic
differences in how they perform in that
situation soon we did research on race
and the experiment I'm going to describe
next is is an example of it it's not
it's not one that we did it's better
than the ones we
so I use it rather than ones we actually
did I like it's better because it used a
real IQ test and used the Ravens
progressive matrices IQ test which is a
test where you've given each item as a
square with a pattern on it big square
with a pattern on it and then there are
five little squares and you have to pick
the little square that continues the
pattern on the big square and they start
out really easy and you think this is
cool but then they get really really
really hard and and nobody almost nobody
can can really get through all of them
so they just get increasingly more
frustrating remember frustration is the
ingredient that makes the stereotype
about your group relevant as an
interpretation of your experience in
this situation so for black students we
made the same reasoning that as they
took this test and went along and
experienced frustration they would the
stereotype would become relevant to them
at some point it would distract them
they worried that their confirming the
stereotype or that there's something
true about it or whatever all that going
on would undermine their performance on
the test and they wouldn't do as well
but if you could give them the same test
with an instruction that made the
stereotype irrelevant as an
interpretation of their performance they
would do just fine on the test it was a
kind of a it felt like a bold prediction
at the time given the broad assumptions
there are about race and ability and
implicit assumptions in this society but
that was the prediction so we gave them
this this brown and day the two
researchers gave these tests to white
students at Oklahoma and black students
at Oklahoma and two of the conditions
they they understood the test to be a
test of intelligence one condition
actually made that explicit another
condition allowed them to assume it but
in the critical condition where we were
they relieved the stereotype threat they
told them that this was not a test of
intelligence it was just a puzzle just a
puzzle had no diagnostic no ability to
diagnose intelligence the two right hand
for you're on your side bars are the
bars where the test is given pretty much
under ordinary circumstances and you see
quite a dramatic under performance by
black students
on this IQ test it's a full standard
deviation which just turns out to be the
exact size of the difference between
black and white IQ in the larger
population a full standard deviation I
would never argue that that stereotype
it alone explains that entire gap so
don't get me wrong here but in this
experiment it did the whole gap whoops
did I just have my hand on that thing
and it moved okay
oh god this is going in the wrong
direction there we go
when the test was seen as a puzzle
though their IQ scores are identical to
those of whites same tests just
represented as a puzzle black scores
here white scores here everybody about
two about the same under those
circumstances another piece of data that
gives you some sense of the power of
this kind of contingency of identity I
can go on there are all kinds of
experiments you can make you can make
white males underperform you know
graduate student engineers at Stanford
you can make them underperform by just
before by telling them just before they
take a difficult math test that Asians
tend to do better at math and whites
tell them that then they get in that
test the frustration starts to happen
they feel themselves confirming not a
negative standing negative stereotype
about their own group but but they're in
the negative light of another group's
positive stereotype and they're
confirming that and since they're very
invested in that in math that's
upsetting and they underperform I wanted
to just mention another study here that
asked experiment a stereotype choice
state it's a little bit off the
narrative but but kind of not it relates
to that second problem I about the
diversity problem of how to make
environments environments that where
people feel in a sense identity safe and
function well together here we were
looking at the kind of stereotype
threats that whites may experience much
more typically than they experience
stereotype threat around intellectual
matters they may experience stereotype
threat in interracial interact
that may be where the situation where
they experience stereotype threat and if
this could have a great deal to do with
the with the experience of being in
integrated settings the idea was simple
that when whites are in an interracial
conversation about something that may be
relevant to race there's this
possibility of being judged or or
treated in terms of that negative
stereotype about whites as racist the
world racially insensitive or something
of that sort that can be a very
upsetting prospect that can have effects
on behaviors in fact it may lead people
to avoid having these kinds of
interactions and that may be one of the
factors that makes these settings
difficult so we did a very simple
experiment you can guess the results of
it as I described it we brought white
males into the lab one at a time and and
we told them they were going to be
having a conversation with two other
students and in one condition the two
other students they saw the pictures on
the table the two other students in one
condition the two other students were
two white guys in another condition the
two other students are two black guys
and they're going to have the
conversation it turns out either about
love and relationships which apparently
college students from pre-testing can
talk to each other very easily about or
they're going to have the conversation
not about that but about racial
profiling so they're going to talk to
either two black guys or two white guys
and they're going to talk either about
love and relationships or racial
profiling the experimenter then says
okay I'm going to get up I'm going to go
get your two conversation partners and
bring them back and by the way while I'm
gone would you arrange the chairs for
the conversation over here and as soon
as they arrange the chairs for the
conversation and you can might imagine
the experiments over that's that's what
we're looking for how do they space
themselves in relation to each other
as a function of these different
possible conversations day they could
have and and the results are something
you can probably predict when they're
going to talk to two white guys about
anything love and relationships or
racial profiling they put the three
chairs very close together and expect to
have a very you know get it on kind of
conversation when they're going to talk
to two black guys about love and
relationships they put the three chairs
very close
- together with each other but when
they're going to talk to two black guys
about racial profiling they put the two
black guys down here and themselves down
here they put distance between them and
this is a kind of dissonant distance as
most typically thought of as reflecting
underlying prejudice but interestingly
what we found was that the in that
critical condition the least prejudiced
people put their chairs the farthest
away the least prejudiced people put
their chairs the farthest away because
in a sense they have the most to lose in
this conversation if it should go awry
on racial profiling with these two black
guys it would really hurt if they were
judged negatively in that situation and
so it's a much more loaded situation for
them for women in math the stereotype
threat has its biggest effect by far on
women who care the most about math under
the most dedicated for it the same with
with with african-american college
students the ones that are care the most
are the ones that are affected by the
prospect of being judged that way caring
makes you vulnerable to this identity
contingency that that's how it works we
also know a great deal about what
happens inside the person while they're
experiencing stereotype threat huge
physiological reactions of all sort
women in under stereotype taking a math
test the prefrontal cortex is suppressed
activity in the prefrontal cortex is
suppressed activity in the amygdala
which is much more sent vigilant to pews
threatening cues in a situation is much
more activated you take stereotype
threat away and the reverse happens
activity and the amygdala Goes Down
activity and the prefrontal cortex goes
up and their performance goes up if you
ask them that this is not to even
mention cardiac reactivity which is very
intense on her stereotypes right but the
interesting thing is if you ask them
about it do you did you experience that
no no there's very little subjective
sense of being under that that
particular stress there's very little
subjective sense of it even though we
can look at the physiological reactions
and see
a great deal to it okay
that's sort of the basic lay of the land
the next question is well what makes
this threat really strong and what makes
it weak what what affects the strength
of this as a psychologist our reflexes
were to say well it must be something
about the individual people who have
lower self-esteem who have lower
expectations about math people who I
don't know just don't think as well of
themselves and don't have as much
resilience we'll show this effect the
most but as I've just said the people
that show this effect the most are the
people that are the strongest they have
the best set of skills the strongest
expectations the most dedication the
most motivation they're not
underperforming in these situations
because they're giving up they're under
for performing because they're trying
too hard
they're just trying too hard they're
grasing through these tests they're
changing their their answers they're
fidgeting and just trying to beat
something that they have relatively
little awareness of so we couldn't go
down the psychological road which is I
think the standard way of thinking about
these kinds of problems we had to go and
become more sociological and look to Q's
and I suppose that's the word that is
the heart of our answer that the
strength the degree to which a person
experiences stereotype threat depends on
the Q's in a situation that suggests
that you might have things to deal with
in that situation because you've got
that identity that's how it would work
I'll give you an example I should say
here that I developed these ideas
following one of your own faculty here
Valerie Purdy Vons who's a professor in
the psychology department we we work
long and hard to just sort among the
various explanations and because she's
given her talk so much on this campus
I'm gonna talk about some other data
that's relevant to it here but but if
you want to hear the real the real dope
on this go hear her talk sometime this
is study that another graduate student
and I did and well this is just to
restate that Q idea think of this as the
math department at Stanford because it
is the
department at Stanford think of yourself
as a graduate student in that office and
think of the right next to the men's and
women's bathrooms there that's a
contingency of identity you have to go
in the right as a function of your
identity you have to go in the right
bathroom or you'll be embarrassed or
arrested I don't know what but it won't
be good but it's so familiar that it
isn't much of a queue that would put you
in mind of of yours of your identity so
I would call that more or less a neutral
queue however and this is the real math
department at Stanford if it looks like
that
where you're the female graduate student
in this office and you would have to go
all the way down the stairs to find the
the women's bathroom in the in the
building that that that queue might make
you aware of a whole host of things you
can see that the queue itself is
completely innocent you know you you
could never police it with laws it's
just and it could be that bathroom could
be put there under the very best of
intentions and everybody in the building
could be pulling for women to do very
well in math but that Q suggests who's
been here what the history of this
discipline is who succeeds in this
discipline who doesn't succeed in this
that q all by itself I remember going to
a Silicon Valley startup a firm once to
pick up a graduate student of mine for
luncheon and I walked in and this I
never felt so old in my life that the
CEO was 26 everybody else he was the
oldest guy working there there was music
playing that I'd never heard before you
know there were bicycles hanging over
people's cubicles it just there was just
so many cues in there that were aged
that sent an age signal to me all
innocent but nonetheless they made me
very vividly aware of having a
particular identity and that if I had to
work in that situation if I actually had
to go to work there you can imagine
those cues innocent though they are
might begin to really have some effect
on my sense of comfort
am i functioning there and the like so
Mary Murphy and I did a very simple
experiment a little devious but
nonetheless very simple we brought women
and and men math and engineering majors
at Stanford into the laboratory one at a
time and they thought the idea was that
they were going to be interviewed for
participation acceptance into a summer
workshop on math and engineering at
Stanford that was the premise and when
they arrived we said well you're also
participating in an experiment after
this and so to save time we would like
right now just to hook you up to all of
this physiological recording equipment
that we happen to have here so we put
electrodes on them and we can measure
this and that and so on so we have now a
measure of their physiology as they wait
for this interview to happen and while
the interview is is while they're
waiting we show them videotapes in one
condition the videotape shows it shows
pictures of the workshop that they're
that they're interviewing for and in one
of the videos there is a one to one
ratio of men to women for every woman
there's a man in the other video for the
other set of subjects it's a three to
one ratio three men for every women for
every woman that's all there is to this
experiment that's all there is just what
if I don't know if I have these pictures
here yeah there they are I like to show
them because when you look at them you
got to look twice to see this it isn't
it is not a big cue it's it's a
relatively subtle cue you can see it but
you have to kind of pay attention okay
here's what happened in this experiment
these these are the results and this is
always going to be the critical cell to
look at these are women who saw the
three-to-one ratio of of men to women
that's the that's what they saw so these
are women who saw looked at this
workshop and saw relatively few women in
it that was the cue well when that
happens interestingly they remember more
details of both the experimental room
and incidental details of the videotape
they remember more of the details that
tells us that what they're doing in that
situation is paying attention to the
circumstances to the condition that cue
has made them vigilant to whether or not
there are features of this workshop that
might be kind of identity vanity issues
and just that ratio makes provokes that
and they start to pay attention to those
things and so they remember them better
think about being the only man in the
room or the only woman in the room if
you're the only man in the room you
start to pay attention you start to
count how many other men are there
what's what are they doing where are
they why aren't they here what's the why
am I here why did the the the just that
kind of processing just starts to happen
and this and this just reflects that
this is just a another memory measure of
the same of the same kind of thing this
is cardiovascular reactivity which I
which I think is amazing to me but look
how much more reactive kardia this is
this is sort of a combination of of
measures of cardio vascular reactivity
pulse and blood pressure and the like
and look how much more reactive they are
than the women and the participants in
the other conditions and it goes along
with the sort of psychological
experience of feeling like you don't
belong in this situation it corresponds
with not belong in this situation ok
cused in and you know again if I could
give Valerie's talk she would show you
another beautiful set of studies looking
at accuse and and the consequences of
them
Lee that's what we think is the source
of things and there's good news in that
in bad news that the bad news is this is
toward remedy I'm getting toward the end
identity threat is intrinsic to most
diverse settings it's the default state
of affairs unless something else is done
now I want to stress here you you can
see that this identity a threat arises
out of the way a situation is organized
around identity which arises out of the
history of this society which arises out
of the continuing differences of
experience in this society based on
group identity and it arises out of all
those things a very
velika no the big picture produces these
things we're talking about how it's
experienced by the individual but I'm
arguing that for all of those reasons we
carry our history into our day-to-day
social experience it's not something you
can just wipe off our identities mean
mean something and that is a fundamental
feature of an integrated setting an
integrated society it has to contend
with that reality is the argument here
and the the good news however is this
some level of salience of identity
safety cues something that makes a
person feel identity safe in a situation
in a setting can foster trust even when
other cues in a setting are otherwise
threatening when I was in graduate
school I won't go into the details but
it was so long ago you can probably
imagine there weren't many blacks there
they weren't well thought of there was a
guy down the hall that would use the
n-word on a regular basis and people
come in discourse in psychology at the
time was the the the racial differences
in IQ and what that meant and whether
they were genetic and this was just
standard fare for those for that era so
there were queues all over the place and
they did make me feel like I didn't
belong and they were and it caused a lot
of stress reactions of the sort that
that I were pulling out in this research
I did have a very good relationship with
my advisor who seemed to I think of
maybe because he was coming up for
tenure and I was his only graduate
student and he needed me so he kind of
believed in me and I could tell you
believed in me because you know he
demanded a lot and he demanded it out
all hours like Sunday nights and all
kinds of of time when I thought I should
be off and and and we really got into
the work and that seemed to do it that
seemed to tell me that he wasn't seeing
me stereotypically and then when I had
that feeling that I had it within this
relationship somebody who could regard
me in this way I began to relax in the
situation the same cues that otherwise
would have been very threatening and
daunting
or pudding and were indeed were just
less so I'm not claiming that there was
any magical miracle cure here it took a
long time to to get used to dealing with
that that kind of situation but but the
fact that there was a relationship there
that that seemed where I wasn't seeing
that way gave me a sense that that I
didn't have to interpret every cue in
the same dire way I had been
interpreting them okay that's the
general principle I think I've got it on
another slide here but it's just a
principle of identity safety that if if
there's a queue if you can give some
somebody a sense of being safe in an
environment you don't have to change
every cue take the bicycles off the
their hooks if you you might you know
play more varied music in that situation
and then what they were playing but you
can be responsive but at the same time
the critical thing the person is looking
for the individual is a sense of safety
they're that their identity is not going
to lead them to have to deal with
difficult things because they've got
that identity ways of doing it they have
begun to I'm so grateful to point out
proliferate in the literature and some
are quite dramatic demonstrations I'm
just going to mention a few I think
leadership is a big deal I've just been
more and more impressed with that as
I've gotten older leaders set the norms
for how institutions function and when
leaders put a good deal of value on
diversity that changes the norms and the
whole sensibility within an institution
from the top down it makes it a much
more identity safe for all of us for all
of the people in it and I think you will
start to see fewer group differences in
performance that it actually translates
into differences in performance that's
the the hard accountability that this
work is holding itself to critical
masses I've just tried to illustrate as
a big deal here's some here's a clever
one how does a white professor give a
black student critical feedback and have
that feedback be trusted simple
experiment we had white and black
Stanford students write essays about
their favorite teacher and we told them
we were going to evaluate these essays
and give them feedback on on the essay
and we did that they had to come back
two days later and get the feedback and
we what we were interested in is whether
they believe the feedback whether they
were motivated to improve their essays
and the like those those were the kinds
of things we were interested in and what
we varied was how do you give the
feedback well how does how does how does
a white guy give feedback in that
situation well there's two things that
didn't work were very interesting just
giving the feedback directly did not
work the black students didn't I trust
that feedback and you can see when you
think about it why it's ambiguous is the
feedback coming from the stereotype or
is it coming from my work I don't know I
just really don't know I'd have to
really trust this guy and why would I
trust this guy to believe that and so
not knowing feeling kind of an big they
don't respond as well to the to the
feedback they aren't as motivated to
improve their essays it doesn't help one
bit yes the evaluator does what most of
us do which is to add before we give the
negative feedback a sort of positive
bromide about the person you know
something like well I really think the
world of your brother and I I've known
your family fro and you seem like such a
warm and wonderful guy here's the
feedback that really is not trusted
black students trusted less and are less
motivated to improve their essays when
they get feedback that way but when the
feedback there is a way that works it's
pretty much like the experience of my
graduate school days that's why I
brought that story up it illustrates it
if you give the feedback you say look
there's some some critical feedback but
I've read your essay and I think that
you can can write a great essay just you
can do really well I really believe
you've got the ability to do well here
this could be a great essay if you work
on this essay that kind of feedback is
just transformative for black students
75% of them in that student in that
condition that group took the essay home
to improve and this was not a course for
credit this was just an experiment the
most that did that any other cell of the
experiment was like
thirty thirty five percent it's is very
powerful feedback for any of us I've
looked at your work and I think you can
do this it can change your life it can
direct your life in a certain direction
it's rare feedback to get but it's
especially a powerful and when don't
when and it for minority students it
disambiguates the feedback and has a
powerful effect tells them they're not
being seen in terms of that stereotype
that's sitting there all the time as the
alternative explanation for what's going
on in this situation
another experiment students are given a
narrative they're coming into college
this happens to have been done in Yale
which I'm realizing his arrival of ours
black and white students they they see
the results of a survey of senior
students and the survey tells them that
look when I came to Yale this is a
survey of of minority students and the
survey says when I came to Yale I felt
really alienated I didn't I felt like I
didn't belong all this gothic
architecture I felt like I had to go
home in the weekend huh on the weekends
how could I ever fit into this kind of a
culture that's just so unconnected to
the culture I've got and so on but
actually I went home and you know my
father got sick of me coming home in the
weekends and said look go back and make
some friends and make the best of it
this is a big opportunity and so I did
that and I made a friend and we started
a singing group and then I we went to
the sociology department I heard a
fantastic lecture and then I went to the
biology department I heard another
fantastic lecture and I I don't know
what I'm gonna do biology or sociology
but I just feel like all the ails got
all this stuff to offer me it's as much
this incredible rich so you see the
narrative it's it's the narrative
acknowledges the stress that the
minority student might be feeling that
the tension that they might be feeling
makes it seem normal and at the same
time projects of a very positive outcome
at the same time well students who saw
that that just took a half an hour their
grades were better two-thirds of the
letter grade better in the next semester
and the same for two years subsequent to
that a a recursive process
arts to have it where you start to feel
this is research that Valerie is also
very close to in another setting Jeff
Cohen is I think the the this particular
study Jeff Cohen and Greg Walton are the
primary guys but their argument is that
a recursive process happens I start to
relax a little bit the cues aren't so
menacing to me as a result of hearing
this narrative about what college can be
like and then I really start to do a
little better and I start to do a little
better and the cues in the situation are
again less less further less threatening
to me and then I start to do a little
better and you get this kind of
recursive process that over time
actually builds confidence and security
in this in this situation and
performance goes goes up up in it the
same thing and this is a study that
Valerie is running as we speak in in New
Haven same thing at the in at the junior
high school level where the effects last
for two years from from a brief
intervention like that which and when I
the the only reason that I might be
tempted that I was initially initially
had doubts could this possibly Detroit
so an intervention that short have that
kind of an effect but now it's been
replicated at the college level has been
replicated in New Haven has been
replicated in Boulder Colorado has been
replicated a number of circumstances and
that this the the the whole notion
hinges on this kind of recursive process
and the data I wish I had the time to
show you sort of reflect it where they
gradually march up and the racial gap in
performance gradually reduces over a
period of time so you you get the image
of a person who's gradually feeling more
and more comfortable and in in this
situation well I could go on by changes
is a list of things but the kind of I
think speak to the importance of this
set of processes these identity
contingencies and in particular this is
the the particular identity contingency
of stereotype threat although there are
others that are just being marginalized
at least to live in Salt Lake City
wasn't race that made me or any
stereotypes about being black that were
the
I was not Mormon and if in that
situation you you don't know what they
think of you you just know you're not at
the center of that of that of that world
so just marginalization alone can be
another form of threat that can begin to
have these these kinds of effects but I
just want to end by summarizing a few a
few principles here by changing the way
you give critical feedback you can
dramatically improve minority students
motivation receptiveness and performance
and always I'm talking about cognitive
performance achievement in school those
are the hard those outcomes I'm talking
about but improving groups critical mass
in a setting you can improve their trust
comfort performance I wish we'd had
these data when when we were at the
Supreme Court because I think we can
make a much more persuasive case about
the value of critical mass to
intellectual development and and and and
progress in an institution by simply
fostering intergroup conversations among
students from different backgrounds I
didn't give you that experiment but
oftentimes just the ability to talk to
each other you reveal that your
experiences are not happening to you
just because you're a member of a
particular group and when they it kind
of leads you to to interpret your
experience less in terms of that group
identity and you begin to relax in this
situation and you're able to engage it
more more easily by allowing students
especially minority students to affirm
their most valued sense of self
sometimes just the opportunity to affirm
a sense of of your worth in a situation
means that the cues that are threatening
you in this situation are just aren't as
important to you they just they're there
but they just aren't as important to you
in this sense of being reminded of your
value in the situation well I can go on
but I think maybe I should stop at this
point and allow people to have some
questions so thank you very much
so we'll have questions both microphones
and please make the questions brief I
just want to say I think we're launching
a Provost that you better be careful
around because he's going to understand
you better than you understand yourself
and that's a dangerous thing we have any
questions yeah you bet Provost what do
you say about those situations in which
the threatening cues are actually
reinforced sometimes by the group with
the identity in question so women who
will raise their daughters telling them
that don't worry about your grade in
math because women aren't any good at
math anyway or in black communities
sometimes particularly in elementary
schools of the early years where
sometimes there is a an idea a foot that
somehow academic success is acting white
so I just throw that out there how do
you what what are some of the remedies
for the situation that results when it's
coming from the group itself that the
the acceptance of the threatening q yeah
I think you raise an important point
because that when it's coming from the
group itself it can be more insidious
and and difficult to to recognize for
what it is and and maybe be more more
threatening there so you know I I don't
know I other than to try to make people
aware of how costly those kind of
remarks can be how much impact it that
they can have they really are
reinforcing the stereotype and and
making it much more powerful in the
lives of of kids the the acting white
data is something that interestingly I'm
thinking of research by roland Pryor
which if guided somehow I'm not kind
pronouncing his last name correct Roland
fryer I think which which documents that
it says that strongest in integrated
schools it's not so strong in more
segregated schools and usually I do get
a question about that well are these
stereotype pressures stronger in
integrated settings than they than they
are in in group homogeneous settings
segregated settings and I think I think
I have to admit that they are stronger
that way that's it's the it's it's the
bringing of these identities together
that creates the the contingencies that
that that I'm talking about how however
I don't want to be seen as advocating
that as the as the remedy and I I would
take I would take all of us the research
the trust of this research as as an
attempt to to try to understand how you
can make a setting work for an
integrated setting work effectively for
everybody and I think we're making
progress on that you know would I argue
that a sophomore math class and in high
school should should never be gender
segregated I'm not sure I'd go that far
I'm not sure I'd be absolute istic about
it there may be circumstances but I
don't think that kind of that
segregation is the general answer to
things I answered two questions there
yeah I was just wondering if you could
explain why in some of the experiments
where they were gender or color neutral
in the way in which the situation was
presented the the woman's performance
and the black performance went up but
the male performance and the white
performance appeared to go down yeah
that has gotten to be a well-known
phenomenon called
stereotyping lift and the idea is that
it's it's slightly advantageous to be on
the upside of somebody else's negative
stereotype and I can imagine how it
works I'm not sure that exactly how it
works has been worked out in research
yet but
if I'm in the group well I do use the
example of being african-american and
being a very lousy basketball player but
having that lousy this be something that
hardly ever discouraged me from from
playing and I can make tons of mistakes
in the in that setting and not really
read it as me being inappropriate to the
setting because that's the setting where
my group does does well with this is our
setting this is you know this is us so
frustration doesn't mean the same thing
depending on how the stereotypes about
your group you know one one I remember
one very poignant experience was going
giving a test once in a in a junior high
school and a difficult math test and all
the students knew that they didn't do
well and you talk to the boys after the
math test and the boys would say that
was the stupidest test I've ever seen
that you know our teacher never covered
any of that stuff and you know and our
teachers not that good anyway
there was no internalization of the you
you the the girls on the other hand
would say you know geez you know maybe
maybe I'm just not so good at math then
and that's that's sort of an example of
how just the overall stereotype
structure of our society and affects the
personal interpretation of experience
and the nature of a person's experience
in a domain that those stereotypes just
implicitly without us having very much
aware of it make certain interpretations
of our emotions sensible and other
interpretations of our emotion less
sensible depending on our identity and
then you start to see the cumulative
effects of that over the course of a
lifetime and you you get a better
insight into how these group differences
start to start to emerge some groups
lifted some groups repressed just
because of the nature of the stereotype
structure of a society so I could see
how one might argue not to
have children and a segregated or an
only sex circumstance but there is also
the argument of armoring somebody
against the future life in which will be
in a very mixed environment and I wonder
if there's any data that would suggest
that sort of critical period phenomenon
for example girls and then all-girls
school where only individual differences
make any difference whether you could
show that there was an effect in later
life of not perceiving that stereotype
threat because it had never been
operative beforehand yes I mean I I
think I have to point to data many of
the women who American women who wind up
in math and quantitatively based fields
have gone to women's colleges women
schools for African Americans
historically black colleges and
universities educate about 17% of the
African American college population
these days but they graduate about 60%
of all those who go into again math and
quantitatively scientifically based
based fields so again I you have to
start with that with with that fact but
I don't it's very important to accept I
think that segregation is not the answer
and as you point out there is some
evidence that going to succeeding in an
integrated situation does Armour one
does enable one to to persist longer and
in subsequent in later levels of
schooling and in one's professional life
yes professor steel my question is a
little bit politically inclined so it
might not be in that good having
psychological research that you were
speaking of so please excuse me if it's
wrongly directed so my question is I see
in society that there are a lot of
political stereotypes about Muslim women
and you know subservient women who
cannot
for themselves who are not as educated
and then you have government you know
trying to reinforce in my opinion quite
negatively by rectifying the situation
themselves and deciding for them what
they can or cannot wear like in France
so I feel pretty strongly about it and I
won't wanted to know like if there was
any research done on that like what kind
of effect is it having on Muslim women
who are perceived to be weak and you
know there are society you know societal
forces deciding for them because they
cannot speak for themselves
yeah I you know I can't answer that
question with any any anything other
than newspaper and knowledge about this
this specific situation that you're
you're talking about so all I could do
is sort of fall back on general
principle and it it's what can I say
it's not a good experience to be
negatively stereotyped in in those ways
and it's going to cause a lot of the
kind of effects that you that you see
documented in in this research it may
not always be in a cognitive domain this
research is focused on stereotypes about
cognitive functioning and we've measured
its effects on those kinds of behaviors
but if but other stereotypes have other
allegations inherent in them and that's
where you would look to see the
consequences of that kind of negative
negative stereotyping I'm sure that
doesn't begin to answer the question you
you have but that would take a lot
longer discussion to to do that good
evening Christy Blake from Earth and
environmental sciences this is a
technical question I was interested in
the results and they're very intriguing
I had not read the original papers I
noticed that the the last set of
histograms you showed had error bars I
presume standard errors in them it was
interesting that the first all the
initial data you showed cut histograms
with nonzero origins and where there
were no error bar shown at all so it was
a little bit hard without knowing the
papers to assess just how significant
the differences were between the various
groups hmm well most meta-analysis I
would say that the average stereotyped
artifact is about six points
the standard deviation this would be
over 1500 studies it's become a huge it
was a cottage industry for a long time
it still is so I apologize for those
features of those those histograms but
the that's what I think you can sort of
take to the bank
as the site as the general size of that
of that effect again the effect can be
made stronger a lot stronger if you're
in a situation where there are where the
queues start to mount up and it can be
made a lot weaker if you're in a
situation where the queues that the
signal stereotype threat as a
contingency are reduced in in a
situation but over all of the studies
that have been done if we just use that
as an indicator that's about the size of
the effects we have two more people
standing for questions let's take both
of those questions and then we'll
conclude there's a reception following I
have a question about I guess the way
these studies we look at kind of
discrete act aspects of identity
intelligence and in the athletic studies
they've done you know looking at
athletics discretely I wonder if those
discrete aspects are kind of
amalgamating to one for instance if you
ask a black student about athletic
ability does that then have a
ramification in terms of tests of
intelligence in other words do they see
the identity as a complete construct of
their psychic ability or their
intelligence their emotional kind of
capabilities or do they kind of look at
it just greatly is that with the data
show yeah I think the the right way to
interpret that is that it depends on
which which stereotype and which
identity are the most salient to the
person I can give you an example in
terms of a study on athletics this is
these are elite athletes at the
University of Arizona you know that
study and they're about to perform a
golf task and in one condition they're
told these are white and black athletes
they're told this is a task of natural
athletic ability do the best you can
under that stereotype the white athletes
go in and underperform in relation to
the black
we all know that kind of stereotyping in
this society so black athletes sail
through white athletes club along you do
this you have them take the same task
but this time you say this is it just
before they take it you say this is a
test of sports strategic intelligence
now when you do that it reverses now the
white athletes do very well on that task
and the black athletes don't do nearly
as well but very dramatic and sizeable
differences in performance so III think
that at least the way I keep these
things straight in my mind is to think
about what what is salient you give
asian women a difficult math test and
for for some of them just before they
take it you remind them of their gender
then they do worse than men others you
remind them just before they take it of
their ethnicity then they do the same or
slightly better than then men so a lot
of it and that this is one of the
optimistic features of the of these of
this set of findings is that is that you
can affect the impact of this by what
you make salient in a performance
situation and you can even coach people
to to make one thing or another thing
salient in a situation a situation okay
so I realize I'm the one keeping
everybody from cashing in on their green
bracelets so I'll keep it short it seems
as though it would be very politically
incorrect to exploit these identities
and yet it seems to be the secret weapon
of advertising I'm a nutrition nutrition
education and I would I can see how
there is a exploitation of someone's
expectation that they aren't going to be
skilled at doing anything so they might
as well buy ready-to-eat food or the
excessive consumption by teenagers on
you know garments that don't need as
much of a markup and so pardon me I
guess I'm kind of asking it has this
actually become sort of
as I say a secret weapon sort of a
hidden way of influencing people to do
more consumerism hmm that's interesting
I don't know I would say my first answer
would be yes but I wouldn't take any
credit for that that is I think of
people intuitively especially when
you're designing ads in the marketing
world that people intuitively may know
that that raising certain ideas about
identity will likely shift people's
attention or their interests or their
preferences and in certain directions
that that there's just a lot of
intuitive use of something like I like
this but I you know I don't know of
anybody kind of reading this stuff and
then and then going out and explicitly
trying to do that but maybe maybe it's
it is happening and I just don't know
about it so I don't know so Claude thank
you for letting us welcome you to
Columbia thank you by insisting that you
give us
you